[Musique]
en provence les fleurs cultivées autour
de grâce ont fait de la ville un rendez
vous incontournable des odeurs et des
parfums mais les agriculteurs sont
nettement moins nombreux qu'au début du
siècle et une partie de la production a
été délocalisée
les entreprises qui résistent le mieux
sont celles qui produisent des parfums
naturels et des parfums de synthèse
les usines de la région reste des
fleurons de l'industrie des odeurs et le
bassin de grâce représente près de la
moitié de l'activité française de la
parfumerie et +2 8% de l'activité
mondiale
aujourd'hui une soixantaine
d'entreprises emploient tissi 3500
personnes dix mille en comptant les
emplois induits
enquête sur un parfum made in france
[Musique]
ces jeunes rêvent de devenir des nez ils
vont être compositeur de parfums
créateur de fragrances leur odorat sera
leur outil de travail
l'école de parfumerie basée à grasse est
l'une des plus renommées dans le monde
l'enseignement se fait en anglais
les élèves sont en grande majorité
étrangers
[Musique]
ils viennent des états unis de serbie de
chine des philippines ou encore du japon
georges n'a pas hésité à parcourir vingt
mille kilomètres pour venir étudier ici
ce néo zélandais pourra devenir un
créateur d'exception grâce à cette
formation
il n'y a aucune formation comparable
dans l'hémisphère sud je voulais venir
en france en particulier parce que
l'histoire de la parfumerie m'intéresse
énormément
éclairer le meilleur endroit pour ça
sinon grâce
les étudiants sont triés sur le volet
chaque année une centaine de candidats
est recalé et seuls 12 élus ont accès à
cet enseignement d'excellence
l'école est très connue jusqu'en tout le
monde dans l'industrie de la parfumerie
rêve devenir au moins une fois dans sa
vie à grasse d'étudier ici et de sentir
toutes les fleurs que l'on ne trouve pas
en mairie
la concentration est intense le nez en
éveil les élèves sont différentes
matières premières ils doivent tenter de
les identifier et surtout de les décrire
de manière olfactives avant de pouvoir
composer un parfum un apprenti doit
maîtriser ses gammes
[Musique]
owentis tard alors qu'il veut commencer
auxquels on sévère à que légèrement
fruitée
pour moi il y a un petit côté crémeux
non
vers la mer vers la mer quelque chose
comme ça oui très bien
les jeunes ont un an pour mémoriser 500
odeur une rude épreuve pour leurs
narines pour réussir il faut pouvoir
s'imprégner d'un maximum de senteurs
fondé cette école dans la ville de
grasse berceau des plantes à parfum
était donc une évidence
c'est pas un travaillant à paris qui
vont allez sentir dès échangeront sur le
banc du périphérique donc il ya toute
une aile il ya toute une histoire il a
toute une histoire de matières premières
naturelles qui est vraiment ancré dans
le patrimoine de grâce et qu'ils
puissent toucher à ça le sens tiers ça
un sens très important pour
cette formation un coup 12000 euros pour
une année mais le retour sur
investissement est garanti séné vaudront
bientôt de l'or un parfumeur renommée
gagne plus de 150000 euros par an à la
fin de l'année à voir ça sur conserver
chars porte
le titre très important
mais imaginez les nouvelles fragrances
pour des maisons de luxe reste l'apanage
de quelques rares créateurs ces
apprentis pourront aussi travailler pour
l'industrie cosmétique alimentaire ou
chimique ils composeront les parfums et
les odeurs qui envahissent notre
quotidien
à quelques kilomètres de l'école est
implanté le leader français de la
parfumerie man a construit un grand
complexe industriel qui s'étale sur plus
de 20 hectares l'usiné emploie ici 1200
personnes
l'entreprise fournit en odeur la plupart
des grandes marques
les parfumeurs de luxe mais aussi les
géants du marché de l'entretien de
l'hygiène et de la beauté
l'entreprise consacre 9% de son chiffre
d'affaires dans la recherche et le
développement
man ne lésine pas sur les moyens et a
même reproduit une douzaine de salles de
bains miniature
ce matin c'est l'odeur d'un
désodorisants qui a testé le spray a été
diffusée dans les cabines avec des
concentrations différentes
je vous l'expliqué pour le test de
classement oui donc là je vais vous
faire classer ces concentrations
différentes donc du moins puissants plus
puissant donc prenez votre temps et
n'hésitez pas à faire un petit tour dans
le couloir si vous êtes trop saturé
70 renifleurs travail dans le
laboratoire ce sont des testeurs
professionnels
rien n'est laissé au hasard
là on sent dans un espace pour que ça
soit similaire
à la vie réelle on va dire en training
elisabeth camping au travail comme
panélistes ici depuis sept ans ça sent
un côté très noire koko exotiques lactée
le laboratoire ressemble parfois à s'y
méprendre un lavomatic à longueur de
journée des serviettes sont lavés avec
de la lessive ou de l'adoucissant
après chaque cycle elles sont empaquetés
de façon hermétique pour que les odeurs
ne s'échappe pas
[Musique]
les lots sont ensuite distribués
le nez des experts peut entrer en action
il faut évaluer pour éventuellement
corriger le parfum du détergent et
ajuster les doses
le créateur de la plupart des senteurs
fabriqués ici c'est lui rolf gaspard
ayant aujourd'hui il doit traiter une
demande particulière un fabricant de
cosmétiques va bientôt mettre sur le
marché un nouveau gel douche pour
enfants qui doit avoir un parfum
suffisamment sucré
adacore gel douche enfants
je trouve qu'il ya un côté un tout petit
peu trop beurré éventuellement pour le
comté plus enfants comme tu disais
pourquoi pas mettre un côté un petit peu
orange pour lever un peu plus ludique je
pense que l'orangé encore une fois ça
devrait lui aller très très très bien on
va regarder notre formule 1
rolf kasparian n'utilise quasiment plus
que des produits de synthèse dans la
formule qui l'a mise au point il a juste
fait appel à un seul ingrédient naturel
l'extrait d'orange du brésil
les produits naturels coûte trop cher et
la très stricte réglementation
européenne pour éviter notamment les
risques d'allergie les rendent
difficilement exploitables
[Musique]
ce qui est assez paradoxal là dessus
c'est que nous sommes très très
restreint en parfumerie sur
l'utilisation de cet orange mais lorsque
vous à l'épaule et une orange pour la
manger vous allez être en contact avec
une quantité d'allergène nettement
nettement supérieure à celle de d'un gel
douche qui serait parfumer avec de
l'essence d'orange par exemple
man occupe aujourd'hui le 7e rang
mondial dans le secteur de la parfumerie
un beau parcours pour cette entreprise
créée à la fin du 19e siècle par des
cultivateurs locaux de plantes à parfum
[Musique]
la société familiale emploie aujourd'hui
plus de 4000 personnes dans 25 pays mais
elle reste attachée à l'usiné historique
de grâce
[Musique]
est le berceau de la société on veut
garder cette image là on investit
beaucoup dans tous les outils pour
maintenir l'acte pour faire perdurer
l'activité va faire progresser améliorer
les process de fabrication toutes les
ressources créatives sont ici après on s
aime ce genre de modèle partout dans le
monde pour conquérir de nouveaux marchés
quarante deux laboratoires comme celui
ci ont été construits à travers le monde
une stratégie qui fonctionne son chiffre
d'affaires a triplé en dix ans pour
atteindre les 700 millions d'euros
i
lusine man n'est pas le seul employeur
de la région la ville de grasse a
d'abord forgé sa réputation grâce à ses
champs de fleurs
au coeur de la provence entre mer et
montagne le climat convient bien à la
culture des plantes à parfum au mois de
mai la rose centifolia embaume les
champs cette fleur est rare elle ne
pousse qu'ici incapable de s'acclimater
un autre sol que celui de grâce
[Musique]
les cueilleuses s'active dès le petit
matin lorsque les boutons viennent à
peine d'éclore
pendant la récolte qui durent quarante
jours 70 saisonniers se relaient un
personnel aguerris originaires du
maghreb qui revient chaque année le
geste doit être précis pour ne pas
détériorer la fleur
[Musique]
fabrice bianchi représente la sixième
génération de cultivateurs sur ce
domaine premières abeilles qui sont là
c'est une fleur qui a besoin
de ce calme et de cette quiétude pour
être ramassées nous ramassons 7 jours
sur 7 il durant cette période là pour
vraiment ramasser une fleurs épanouies
plénière a vraiment essayé d'obtenir on
va dire une qualité olfactives la plus
la plus importante
l'enjeu est de taille car les fleurs
termineront dans ce flacon
le parfum numéro 5 de chanel la grande
maison française hachette l'intégralité
de la production
sophie vergès représente la marque de
luxe
[Musique]
ça s'annonce une bonne récolte en termes
de production j'ai l'impression que tu
as mangé sur
la finir
chanel ne peut pas délocaliser ou alors
acheter de la rose bulgare marocaines et
égyptiennes qui serait pourtant plus
économique car aucune autre fleur n'a le
même parfum
l'odeur acidulées de la centifolia est
unique et inimitable
le parfumeur français n'a donc pas
d'autre choix que de se fournir à drass
[Musique]
aujourd'hui la volonté en tant qu'acteur
majeur de la parfumerie et la sueur et
une pérennité olfactive de la formule
d'où la nécessité en fait de se garantir
des filières de production pour ne pas
avoir à modifier nos formules qui
amènerait à un changement de l'odeur du
parfum le luxe c'est aussi ça pour nos
consommatrices de leur garantir en fait
que le numéro 5 de 1921 est exactement
le même que celui de 2015
la démarche que l'on a est vraiment une
démarche
effectivement d'un produit de lutte en
1987 un partenariat est donc conclu
désormais ces cultivateurs ont poussé
trois hectares de rose et 7 ha de jasmin
exclusivement pour la marque haute
couture
pour nous c'est une assurance évidente
ne pouvoir avoir comme partenaire la
maison chanel nous travaillons en
confiance il n'y a pas de stress lié à
notre travail à notre quotidien
mais comme pour tout agriculteur c'est
une économie fragile et risqué les
cultivateurs sont à la merci de la météo
une mauvaise saison et leur chiffre
d'affaires peut être plombé
le parfum des roses est également
délicat une fois la fleurs cueillies
c'est une course contre la montre qui
s'engage
la remorque par immédiatement vers l'
usine qui se trouve à deux pas sur la
propriété
[Musique]
les sacs sont pesées
chanel rémunère les cultivateurs en
fonction de la quantité produite
jean-françois vieille et l'expert de la
transformation des fleurs
250 kg de rose remplissent la cuve la
technique est la même depuis le début du
20e siècle
[Musique]
un solvant chauffer capture les
molécules parfumée
cette heure plus tard les fleurs sont
méconnaissables
elles sont cuites et décoloré
[Musique]
e
si le service logiciel je revenais pas
mais pour faire du parfum elles nous ont
donné le pare-feu ghezzal et
cette transformation donne à concentrée
solide appelé concrètes
c'est donc rennes n'est pas utilisée
directement par l'auteur fumeurs parce
qu'il ya une partie qui est insoluble
dans l'alcool donc ce produit on à leurs
experts avec de l'alcool pour ne garder
que la partie soluble et on à obtenir un
produit qu'on appelle la police était ce
produit qui va rentrer dans la
composition des partenaires 230000
centifolia sont nécessaires pour
produire un kilo d'absolu vendu près de
20000 euros une pure folie que seules
les grandes maisons peuvent s'offrir
[Musique]
même s'il ne reste plus que dix
cultivateurs de plantes à parfum grâce
la ville provençale reste encore
aujourd'hui la plaque tournante des
odeurs c'est un carrefour on se retrouve
toute la profession de la parfumerie
le numéro un mondial de transformation
de produits naturels mêmes bases et ici
en mai lusine roberte et tourne à plein
régime grâce à la rose centifolia
l'expert des matières premières de
lusine robert sinigaglia réceptionne les
fleurs en personne
ça c'est de la fleur qui a été prêté qui
a été accueilli vers 8h30 9h les
sciences de la vie
et ça c'est de la peur qui était
co-leader 10h30
on doit tout de suite ça c'est clair
cette usine familiale ne traite plus
uniquement les fleurs locales à peine 5
% de ce qu'elle transforme vient de la
région en 160 ans d'existence
l'entreprise s'est diversifiée
de la cardamone du guatemala du mat et
du brésil
où des clous de girofle de madagascar
roberte est extrait parfois l'odeur de
produits plus étonnant le foin est très
utilisée en parfumerie ici ce sont des
sacs de tabac bulgare qui s'apprête à
offrir toutes leurs effluves
la palette d'odeurs ne connaît pas de
limites plus de 400 ingrédients en
provenance de 60 pays sont transformés
ici
depuis les années 60 l'entreprise mise
sur une croissance externe en rachetant
d'autres usines de la région elle
développe également des filiales dans le
monde entier
aujourd'hui si on veut faire des
produits si on veut continuer à
développer notre secteur d'activité
impérativement donc prennent cette
option sur d'autres pays à mende pour
elle est fabriquée sur place nous mêmes
des produits parce qu'on prend pas les
importer le jasmin 1 2 ne s'impose pas
ils n'arriveront pas ici on s'est
ressaisi des produits qui ne voyagent
pas de seconde balle correctement on
peut faire transporter des végétaux des
matières premières sèches mais les
produits floraux ne se rapporte pas
voilà
pourtant pas question de parler de
délocalisation
l'entreprise ne licencie pas en france
si certains procédés de transformation
sont faisable à l'étranger lusine
historique garde jalousement des
connaissances qui ne peuvent être imité
comme la fabrication de l'absolu
ce n'est pas oublié comment un
savoir-faire de
[Musique]
logis s'apprend pas le jour
robert tu es content aujourd'hui 1800
salariés et génère un chiffre d'affaires
annuel de près de 400 millions d'euros
les concentrés d'odeurs naturelles et de
synthèse qui font la renommée de grâce
sont convoitées par les parfumeurs à
travers la planète
les élus locaux se sont battus pour que
l'industrie grassoise prennent le cap de
la mondialisation
l'industrie la parfumerie s'en sortent
très bien puisqu'elle exporte à 70% son
chiffre d'affaires mais le père paul
grassois est aujourd'hui le pôle qui
représente plus de la moitié du chiffre
d'affaires national dans le domaine et
entre 8 et 10% du chiffre d'affaires
mondial c'est pas rien pour un petit
territoire qui pire cette force de son
passé
la tradition remonte au 16e siècle
à l'origine c'est un tanneur grassois
qui al'idée de parfumer ses gants pour
en masquer l'odeur désagréable
le succès est fulgurant
rapidement les bourgeoises de toute
l'europe viennent non pas lui réclamer
ses gants mais ces fragrances grâce
devient alors la capitale mondiale du
parfum
[Musique]
jusqu'au début du 20e siècle toute la
ville vit de la culture et de la
transformation de la fleur
mais là-bas d'oeuvre coûte très cher les
parfumeurs se tourne peu à peu vers les
colonies du bassin méditerranéen puis en
inde et en chine pour se fournir en
plantes odorantes
à partir de 1960 la synthèse prend le
pas sur le naturel les usines ferment ou
sont absorbés par des géants de la
chimie pour survivre les entreprises
grassoise n'ont d'autre choix que de se
mettre elles aussi à fabriquer des
produits de synthèse pour la parfumerie
et les arômes alimentaires
en un siècle le nombre de parcelles
cultivées s'effondre passant de 1800
hectares en 1930 à peine une
cinquantaine d'hectares aujourd'hui
[Musique]
le parfum c'est une histoire ce sont
aussi des hommes
grâce à donner c'est plus beau nez à
l'industrie mondiale notamment edmond
roudnitska disparu en 1996 qui est
considéré comme le plus grand nez du 20e
siècle on lui doit notamment au sauvage
de dior diorissimo ou encore l'eau
d'hermès
sont dont il l'a transmis à son fils
michel crée lui aussi des parfums
l'orga parfum c'est comme la palette
d'un peintre à sa disposition 400
ingrédients naturels et de synthèse
autant de couleurs olfactives une eau de
toilette ou un parfum contient entre 30
et 50 éléments
les ingrédients sont pesées avec
précision la création peut commencer
[Musique]
ça peut prendre des années tout dépend
bond de son inspiration 6/10 et des
idées sont claires si on a déjà réfléchi
mature et la formule et quand on a juste
à la mettre en oeuvre et parfois on part
de zéro et on la sait là disons là le
champ vierge mystère complet
le parfum va un peu à peu se construire
un parfum se compose de trois notes
perceptible progressivement au fur et à
mesure de leur évaporation les notes de
tête sont les premières effluves et se
volatilise vite viennent ensuite les
notes de coeur qui tiennent de quelques
minutes à 2 heures enfin les notes de
fond qui peuvent persister des jours
voire des semaines entières
tout la construction d'un parfum ça
consiste à justement
à construire quelque chose qui soit à la
fois harmonieux à la fois équilibrée
mais qu'ils puissent tenir dans le temps
et qui se développe avec une certaine
continuité avec à la fois des variations
mais ces variations que se font les unes
dans les autres c'est là la grande
difficulté ce qui fait que c'est un art
c'est que justement on doit savoir
marier les matières premières on doit
les connaître
michel roux de nice qu'à créer des
parfums pour des marques de niche haut
de gamme le laboratoire à flanc de
montagne jouit d'une vue imprenable
je
chaque jour le parfumeur déambulent dans
les allées de son jardin escarpé pour
ceux nés c'était une évidence de
travailler au milieu de cette végétation
luxuriante dans les traces de son père
dans ce jardin on a essayé de de réunir
un certain nombre de plantes aromatiques
qui nous sert d'inspiration donc
incomplet les sentiers régulièrement on
a des roses à notre du jasmin des
freesias d'
climatique
on était vraiment une parfois sublime
très fruité du côté de liqueur de prune
vraiment merveilleux
ces fleurs odorantes ont rendu célèbre
grâce dans le monde entier
[Musique]
le parfum fait aussi vivre une industrie
touristique la ville de 57 milles
habitants accueille chaque année deux
millions de visiteurs
hôtels restaurants et magasins de
souvenirs bénéficient de ce rayonnement
les vacanciers les plus curieux
s'aventure jusque dans les champs
[Musique]
ya un geste précis pour la cueillette
donc insu il nous suffit d'avoir donc
ces trois doigts là on passe de chou le
pouf dedans et on casse
on écoute
[Musique]
les touristes aiment découvrir les
fleurs mais surtout les secrets de
fabrication du parfum
fragonard l'une des plus anciennes
usines du centre ville est aujourd'hui
le site industriel le plus fréquenté de
france
[Musique]
fragonard mise beaucoup sur sa clientèle
internationale et n'hésite pas à
embaucher des guides étrangers les
explications peuvent se faire en 18
langues pour glass works et chapman
échec tameka
les touristes apprennent l'origine du
parfum et admire la magie de la
conception ces visites gratuites
remporte un vif succès l'entreprise
accueille un million de visiteurs chaque
année
face à cet engouement fragonard se
développe depuis 15 ans et possède
aujourd'hui 23 points de vente
des boutiques ouvrent régulièrement sur
la côte d'azur à paris mais aussi à
l'étranger où le made in grâce est une
valeur reconnue
les industriels les cultivateurs comme
les élus locaux ont bien compris
l'intérêt d'un tel attrait pour le tissu
économique local
ils se mobilisent aujourd'hui pour faire
inscrire la parfumerie grassoise à
l'unesco comme patrimoine immatériel de
l'humanité
[Musique]